hey that's how the last movie started
also reading also if I'm supposed to be
reading and absorbing all this goo and
if there's a quiz I'm keying your car
teach as we're about to see the Empire
is going to get their asses kicked yet
again with Luke Skywalker leading the
charge aside from the Death Star during
this entire series we never see the
Empire bring an aerial attack on a
planet they just send down these
cumbersome and Bureau walkers so what
did they do to actually win something
for once and if they were winning why
were so many of the rebels allowed to
flee across the galaxy okay so this is a
remote ice planet I'm assuming where no
one really lived before because it's
cold of them but the rebels came here
and then found tamed and learned how to
ride the indigenous tauntaun and built a
whole base inside the mountain in three
years
and no one from the Empire had any idea
don't you think this was a little like
the Oregon Trail for a while you have
died of dysentery well that was some
convenient timing assuming this planet
is not super tiny what are the odds
Luke's patrol coincides perfectly with
the probes arrival Betty girl hey what's
the matter discount horse movie rips off
Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer is
abominable snowman thankfully for Lou
this species of snow monster drags its
prey back to the cave before fully
killing it holy Sh who woulda guessed
that of all three movies including the
one where she wears a bikini that this
would be the sexiest lay a moment of all
discount Hoth chic c-3po I decided to
stay well the Bounty Hunter we ran into
in Ord Mantell changed my mind
first off Han refers to some other
adventure we had no context for unless
we read the books say no han decides
it's time to go because he ran into a
bounty hunter on some other planet who
obviously doesn't know where he is now
it's been three years doesn't actually
think it's best to risk his freedom by
going to Jabba now excuse me son like
I'm covering robots mouth actually stops
it from making noise oh who knew the
speeders ready uh not yet we're having
some trouble adapting them to the cold
which is weird because everything else
works on this planet regardless of Cole
your toes I'll freeze before you reach
the first marker we'll see you in hell
hungry won't blow decided to knock out
Luke and put him in the fridge before
eating him and Luke has been dangling
upside down unconscious for who knows
how long look running to his head and
before you go telling me his Jedi ways
helped him avoid traditional
physiological problems like that I will
point out his Jedi ways did Jack and to
help him avoid landing in this situation
to begin with the real question is how
did that lightsaber manage to fall close
enough to Luke for this but far enough
away that it couldn't just slipped out
of his holster and fallen straight down
I get me going for here I really do but
in the last movie you showed me this
asshole using the force
blind to deflect unseen laser blasts
from a drone how can he do that but not
this what is it about this series and
cutting arms or hands off
Luke is smart right why doesn't he just
kill that thing and stay in the cave han
so worried about nightfall he's headed
out to find Luke and he does but only
because Luke is stupid enough to wander
out of the cave just before nightfall so
Luke left the beasts cave fell
unconscious for a bit but then went back
up and started walking again really
luckily for Luke and Han this planet's
freezing temperatures do not lead to
hypothermia and quick death
oh this asshole only shows up in the
absolute most extreme Luke might die
situations
why couldn't appear to Luke four hours
earlier and say Luke do not explore the
meteorite you saw you will go to the
Dagobah assist provided of course that
on sticks you in a dead tauntaun so that
you can live also the dig Abbas system
sounds racist there you will learn from
Yoda the Jedi Master who instructed me
sorry I didn't tell you this sooner over
the last three years I was baking
brownies minutes in my time or years in
your time I still say that in all the
Star Wars movies the most unbelievable
thing is that Han somehow finds Luke
during dusk on a huge snow planet
tonton X market how does Hans - fluke
into a tauntaun belly they're not much
bigger than humans Han somehow survives
the bitter cold all through the night
without getting inside the tauntaun
himself that sounded dirty but Han
should be frozen much like Luke was a
minute ago why is this asshole flying up
and down over the hills rather than just
flying over the hills
does he like to cheat death on rescue
missions hot spa also these things have
very little privacy this guy is to rehab
in front of everyone in a diaper I don't
know where you get your delusions laser
brain what's worse this lame-ass insulin
to the fact that Chewie found it funny
neither the force nor obi-wan has told
Luke about Leia being a sister yet even
though it's been three years this must
be a massive very dark practical joke
translation this is some fucked up right
here it's metal then it couldn't be one
of those creatures could be a speeder
one of ours
you mean the speeders you were just told
last night can't go out Nicole can we
all at least agree then to this one
instance han shot second that is the
system and I'm sure Skywalker is with
them set your course for the Hoth system
look if you're sure as you say wanted to
take a drill report and a photograph for
you to figure out Skywalker's location
the rebels are alerted to our presence
Admiral Ozzel came out of Lightspeed too
close to the system-wide invader
specifically in order not to do that or
is the movie saying no one could have
possibly known that invaders just being
a dick sir rebel ships are coming into
our sector good our first catch of the
day after one small ship beat the Death
Star ignorance and confidence are the
same thing so you can land these things
outside the energy shield but you can't
get some quick fighters down here to
perform an aerial assault look these
things are awesome in many ways but that
doesn't mean they make sense besides how
are these things not using tracks like
tanks to move they needed to use actual
freaky legs also movie completely
glosses over how much slippin and slidin
should be going on with all the snow and
ice whoa group use your harpoons and tow
cables go for the legs why the hell do
these small fighters have tow cables for
towing a 1974 Buick and harpoons for I
guess whaling
goddamn falling down makes these
Imperial walkers go for bulletproof to
flammables hell the birthing process
between walkers on Hoth was accelerated
tenfold and the baby is already walking
I didn't even see anything so this is
amazing ku klux stormtrooper luke
survives this crash honestly how do you
guys even build all this underground
infrastructure in snow anyway this
bucket of bolts is never gonna get past
that blockade that's kind of true but
why was Luke's x-wing somehow able to
get through the blockade no problem man
ship is always taking off just in the
nick of time and while being shot at I'm
sure it takes off under normal calm
circumstances plenty of times but we
don't ever seem to see it vader senses
or sees the falcon leave but does not
apparently since his son Luke fellow
force user a few hundred feet above him
on the snow okay so I can use the Force
two maybe even slightly not the ship off
course and crash it into the mountain as
we learn from Yoda size doesn't matter
so why not at least try or rather do
because there is no truck here's another
thing how are there not any Imperial
ships guarding the exit off the planet
we even heard them talk about a blockade
earlier so where is it and the rebels
didn't find some other side of the
planet where the blockade wouldn't
affect them so what gives two of these
three Star Destroyers pursuing the
Falcon run into each other
how is that possible how do you not see
another starter story or in your path do
you not have radar training skill who's
flying the ship right now Leia autopilot
evasion software
there was no laser blast on earth like
an asteroid how does an asteroid hit you
and you're not dead yet water creatures
in the Star Wars franchise never find
the heroes tasty oh yeah and how is our
two still working right now and all that
sludge in his system whoa that does not
look like James Earl Jones at all does
that even though shutting me down - no I
need you to talk to the Falcon find out
what's wrong with the hyperdrive but he
just said what was wrong with the
hyperdrive a few minutes ago didn't he I
noticed earlier the hyperdrive motivator
has been damaged and you didn't fix it
because you hit the asteroid field
before you could do anything so that's
still the problem right I'm looking for
someone okay that someone you have I
would say tonight don't unsolved
mysteries we'll try to figure out where
Yoda sense of humor went after this one
scene in the Empire Strikes Back
Luke's dinner consists of Cheetos blocks
that look like cheese some sort of white
candy or pills hush puppies and strips
of drywall you
kyouda you know him mm-hmm
take it to him area just like obi-wan
Yoda initially pretends not to be the
person he actually is mostly just to put
the audience I mean Luke I believe it
says that the power coupling on the
negative axis has been polarized is that
another way of saying the hyperdrive
motivator is damaged or is this some
completely new invented bullshit reason
for the hyperdrive not to work i
isolated the reverse power flux coupling
the cen c-3po stands for cut block where
the this wire hologram is just shooting
out of the floor here why are there
screens in some instances and random
holograms and others no this boy is the
offspring of Anakin Skywalker which is a
weird thing to say to Anakin Skywalker
also didn't the very fact that his name
is Luke Skywalker tip you off you can't
seriously expect us to believe that
after Luke destroyed the Death Star the
Empire didn't hear what the hell his
name was also Luke was hidden on another
planet so the Darth Vader couldn't find
him yet he kept the name Skywalker I did
not teach him the boy has no patience
Yoda talks about Luke to a ghost in
front of Luke and this is his way of
revealing himself to actually be Yoda
this one a long time have I watched all
his life has he looked away to the
Future the horizon maybe because you
assholes stuck him on it he distant
planet with his and uncle and gave him
no other type of future to look forward
to how the hell do you blame him for
that are you saying if you'd stuck
around on Tatooine and enjoyed dusting
crops you'd have flown out here like
magic to train him I think not either
way he's not a Jedi what you are
reckless so was i if you remember
obi-wan is basically Jedi coast lawyer
here yes drew oh is Yoda cranky
does he not really want to Train Luke
why the 100 excuses thing I know we're
building tension for the audience I mean
Luke but other than that why is he so
resistant this movie is basically saying
ghosts obi-wan is wiser than 800 year
old Yoda which is just being stupid cool
for sure but how does it creature this
giant survive on an asteroid with little
to no food available a Jedi uses the
force from knowledge in defense never
for attack but tell me why I kill no
there is no way
Jedi Master gets frustrated with obvious
questions I thought you assholes were
supposed to be at peace with everything
even annoying trainees
please be strong with the dark side of
the force a domain of evil it is it's a
domain of evil sitting around just being
evil in the Dagobah system
the for your bad packets you will not
need them because you see this evil
domain strong with the dark side of the
force out in the middle of nowhere it
just well it's here for psychological
reasons in the unlikely case someone
comes down here it's a strict Freudian I
hear what will really bake your noodle
is what this would have been if Luke
hadn't brought his weapons with it also
face your adversary at a dream before
facing them in real life cliche someone
set this video game to the EC setting
symbolism also Luke cuts off dream
Vader's head and sees his own face
inside and still can't figure out what's
going on the force is literally
screaming the truth Adam but he's not
listening
so Darth Vader's orders are that he
wants the passengers a lot so why are
these millions of green lasers getting
shot at the ship right now what happens
if one of these things ends up
destroying the ship why not
do or do not there is no try luminous
beings are we not this crude matter
Yoda breaks the teacher-student boundary
rule okay so after this big talk about
how rocks and spaceships are different
from each other and size doesn't matter
and all that jazz Yoda then proceeds to
power the ship out of the water but with
considerable effort I might add if the
force supposedly doesn't distinguish the
size of objects this thing should have
emerged immediately I don't I don't
believe it Nik is why you fail pimp I'm
taking a sin off for that too Yoda is
too badass
captain photo this time you've gone too
far
what the hell is he blabbing about gone
too far in what way this is an amazing
move of considerable cunning and it got
them out of being captured or killed it
at the very least bought time even if he
didn't have a plan after that instead of
waiting even a few minutes after
floating away with the garbage before
taking off on takes off immediately
thereby allowing himself to be trail
buhbuh that makes one of the luckiest
guesses ever and has himself shot out
with the trash to follow the Falcon just
in case it was doing the old attach
yourself to the big ship so it can't be
read by their scopes and leaving the
empty other trash trick also why can't
the Falcon detect the ship right behind
it
mysteries now help them you
you would despite all forward spam fuck
and suffer because your dad is Darth
Vader and he can turn you to the dark
side and the rebels would lose the war
well that's a spoiler for the audience
that you the most important character in
this movie is just better off not know
welcome Leia Leia isn't pregnant with
Lando's baby already it is you and your
abilities the Emperor once and also
Darth Vader is your fuck damn I can't
tell them that until the big surprise
ganna if you end your training now you
choose the quick and easy path as Vader
did you will become an agent of evil
except he doesn't so in your face false
prediction Yoda that boy is our last
hope
No there is a doctor kind of makes you
wonder what would happen if Luke got
killed or turned to the dark side
bleh I have received a vision to go to
dig'em ah somehow but Yoda would have
died before she got there leaving nobody
to train her
I'm guessing her training would
consisted of going to the library
learning Jedi Master from microfiche and
also stuff about demons lots and lots of
demons 3po wait
aha proof that Cloud City is funded by
Gringotts
I'm surprised Vader didn't shoot on
first I had no choice there right right
before you did
how did they do that even if Bubba Fett
tells Vader that they're going to Cloud
City immediately after he starts
following the Falcon the Falcon is a
huge head start and this is after the
Star Destroyers went into light speed in
a different direction
Empire scientists create another what
the fuck is that thing for torture
device it looks like it's made of at
least five failed science projects this
contraption does things so horrible it's
better left off-screen because whatever
bolt that thing is doing is probably
bull but it sure does hurt oh yes that's
very good I like c-3po reconstructive
porn dialogue
oh my you've done i back would you Bobbo
you know c-3po was kind of an annoying
character in the first movie but lovably
so an empire he's a whiny know-it-all
who's actually kind of mean I love you I
know no Walt Disney Skywalker's just
landed Lord good see to it that he finds
his way in here awesome how do I do that
do you think he'd respond to breadcrumbs
what the it's David Copperfield pushing
that thing i Lando so now despite the
scene it's still ad murat bar that is
most remembered for saying it's a trap
also like any hero in any adventure luke
ignores his friends warning that it's
all a trap because the power of space
boners is stronger i actually succeeded
in following Vader's orders to lead Luke
here by parading the prisoners around in
circles below this arena until he showed
up apparently oh come on
this is one of those things where I
understand but I don't understand he
just risked his own neck to take you out
of custody but we're going to waste time
with trust issues after a baller move
like that just don't need any of your
help really like the kind that just
freed you from captivity so you could
escape you don't need that kind of help
put Captain solo in the cargo home
unnecessary orders are so the good guy
is running directly by random spot r2d2
just happened to wind up cliche obi-wan
is talk to you
why does fader assume that obi-wan
taught Luke and we know that Luke
doesn't quite have ahold of his thoughts
at his emotions yet so how does Yoda not
pop into Darth Vader's head and if dead
obi-wan could have done the training why
did Luke even have to go to the Dagobah
system already this lightsaber battle is
complex enough to confirm my suspicions
that Vader was merely humoring obi-wan
last movie hmm
Vader starts using the Force to throw
objects at Luke during the battle which
not only feels like cheating but also
makes me wonder why he doesn't do more
of that well here's the Millennium
Falcon again taking off amidst yet
another hail of laser fire there goes
another limb no one just gets stabbed by
a lightsaber in this series do they
obi-wan never told you what happened to
your father
for reasons pretty unclear considering
II would be finding out anyway via the
force or in this case dramatic reveal to
the audience 8ball me you healed me I am
your father
we're gonna get a supreme bolt
explanation for this discrepancy airway
circle feedings you know it to be true
it requires about ten syllables to say
no in Tatooine English or tattoo English
also no movie paint suicide is the noble
choice
Luke falls off a bridge basically to his
death and then is saved by this thing I
don't know what it is or if Luke knew it
would do this but what a crazy asshole
random this is well if the antenna isn't
an ex machina dim somehow grabbing onto
it while falling definitely is look
someone's up how can you tell that from
this distance father Dan he went right
into the acceptance phase of that
shocker didn't he yeah why didn't you
tell me because if he had it wouldn't
have been a big whammy for the audience
how can this character not know he's in
a movie for chrissake you guys have
hyperdrive right meanwhile here is a
load of rebel ships that managed to
somehow escape the hoff blockade without
incident we didn't show you that because
we showed you the Millennium Falcon's
escape attempt but it totally happened I
promise
you are the father
any girl hey what's the matter you smell
something there is no spoon hmm
oh here's a fun fact you made out with
your sister man Joey take care of
yourself okay brothers got a odd thief
it's what's for dinner
James T Creek any offense no both
I'm wearing a Viridian patch of my back
Spock slapped that there just before we
went on talking ship r2 says the chances
of survival are 725 to one we don't
quote me the price when I haven't got
the time
Tommy as a peeping
Tommy that's a big thing I have a
dropping no eaves sir honest I cannot
teach him the boy has no patience hmm
friend you have there they were in pain
you have the sight now kneel there are
two rules to remember if you want to
have a good time
rule number one never run out of coal 45
will number two never forget rule number
one